Victor gathers job as a journalist to
the fact-checking agency is to verify
information on the internet and examine
the truth to what government and
political leaders are saying he
especially needs to be more diligent
during the corona virus pandemic Nia has
just analyzed the social media video of
the governor of Kenya's capital Nairobi
Mike's Hong Kong who recently included
bottles of a brand of cognac in food
relief packs and gave this explanation
which has some percentage of alcoholic
content and that should act as a strong
sanitizer it gives the virus the virus
it's a sermon that it gives as the
disease continues to spread across the
continent
so does misinformation about it a lot of
false information in a lot of
misinformation and disinformation play
on your emotions and when people are
emotional the country they can be
critical it's only this product in the
world that gives the virus in Uganda
President Yoweri Museveni recently
endorsed the production of a sanitizing
spray that a medical investor said could
cure the disease Madagascar's president
andrew raja lena also launched the
distribution of a hobbled drink he said
Calaveras and Kenya some people are
using home remedies they swear will
protect them from getting sick the World
Health Organization has said there's no
proven cure or vaccine these are
confusing times for everybody many
people are now relying more on online
content for their coronavirus update
some of those we talked to say they are
overwhelmed by all the information on
social media others say they are relying
on so-called cure recipes they seen
online and most of this false
information has been shared millions of
times across the continents
Maryna Kenya's a volunteer with a Kenyan
Red Cross she distributes sanitizers
soap and masks on the streets of Nairobi
and offers accurate information as
opposed to the misinformation online
other people are telling us that they
are drinking a lot so it means they
cannot contact the virus and they're
people who believe that coffee 19 is not
for Africans they are saying that thing
is in fact this morning someone carried
me and he told me cover 19 is just for
rich people he doesn't believe in that
she says the only way to counter the
online misinformation is doing what she
is doing talking to people answering
their questions and trying to calm their
fears
Katherine SOI al Jazeera Nairobi Kenya